hey what a glorious day and on this
video i wanted
to say a massive heartfelt thank you
to you for watching these videos and
being the subscriber
i'm celebrating in fact yesterday was my
six year youtube anniversary
which coincided with the anniversary of
my 1
000th youtube video it's just absolutely
crazy
it was only when i posted it when one of
my subscribers said hey do you realize
that this is your anniversary both in
terms of thousands youtube videos but
also six years so
i wouldn't have even known if it wasn't
for my subscribers telling me things
like this
and it's just really made me reflect
today over the last six years and kind
of what's happened on youtube
i sent my youtube channel up initially
really just for my
investors who were buying property deals
off me because i wanted to give them
some content
thank you very much indeed yes
four double bedrooms prime location
right in wolverhampton center
will get easily 1400 pounds rent
and the total cost for the house 85
grand
i'm happy with that and it just
snowballed and it's just grown
so as i reflected over the last six
years what's happened
i thought i'd share some of those
reflections with you and
really in the spirit of just saying
thank you for being a subscriber
so i mean the first thing that really
started blowing my youtube channel up
was the financial freedom challenge that
i did where i just said you know what
i'm going to start all over again from
scratch
and i was dumped into a random city
which was sheffield good to meet you
how come you're wearing a microphone
oh i am samuel yes
so what are the adventures of the cover
where you like the [ __ ] in our room
that was something else right now we
have no car
no money we've been kicked out of the
networking event
but we do have a deal we just need to
find a joint venture partner do you
reckon i'll publicly say something
oh became financially free
in one week and not only did i become
financially free again from scratch
but i also showed exactly step by step
how i did that and that got picked up by
the bbc news
this sounds quite interesting but a
little bit risky you had 50 pounds that
was all
and a hotel room and you had to then
make money
it burst a lot of excuses for people
because people had previously been
saying that they didn't have the money
they didn't have the um you know the the
the background to be able to become
financially free it bust the excuses
then people said but samuel i live
overseas i live in america
i live in i live in australia i live in
different parts of europe i live in
africa
so my next big challenge was i went to
an airport
got my phone out and said i'll go
anywhere you want me to go
right here right now and start from
scratching property and watch me do
deals
so uh just arrived at london heathrow
i don't know where some of these places
are cape town barcelona
new york uh will joyce says new york as
well
okay new york yeah i mean i'm coming
i'll go freaking
anywhere i really don't care where does
the next plane go to go to
the next plane jfk
i'll have to visit ghana as well soon
america
i'm coming for you baby and i ended up
in america
where i did my next viral financial
freedom challenge in america
and then people started saying can you
do the financial freedom challenge with
me can you do it with me
so i traveled all over the world doing
speaking engagements
running property investors crash courses
i went and lived with glenn
who many of you will remember in
blackpool where i lived with glenn for
seven days and helped glenn become
financially free you always think it
will happen to someone else
and then when it happens to you you
everything changes my purpose which is
to ask you one question
and that is will you allow me to be the
person that you do the financial freedom
challenge with
i saw the video that samuel put on his
youtube channel saying that he's looking
to go to someone's house
and work with them and make them
financially free and i thought
that has to be me like whatever happens
that has to be me
so i found out when his next crash
course was and i went down to london and
i was really nervous i stood up got a
microphone and i asked the question
would would you allow me
to be the one to do the financial
freedom challenge with and everyone just
started clapping
[Music]
[Applause]
as soon as i started talking about my
health and my situation and my finances
i feel like that i felt a real release
that everyone kind of saw in me
the pain that i'm in and the struggle
that i'm going through at the moment
and i felt really lifted and when samuel
said yes
i just knew that
you know the rescue boat had come to
save me i'll come to your house
[Applause]
which was absolutely amazing um and
inspired
hundreds of thousands of people not just
in the uk but overseas
and then i ended up doing the same again
with evans and lawton and david
i'll tell you exactly how much i make on
this property i make
nothing on this house and the reason i
make nothing
is this is our house this is where we're
gonna be staying
this is our apartment what do you mean i
just want to thank you for everything
you're gonna make me cry um you've
helped me from like
from the bottom i just want to let you
know that you know i got you for life
so uh so we've secured this this is our
home
[Music]
i love you so much and i love this
apartment it's
so perfect are you serious for real
serious
yeah she's serious i am this luck is
what do you mean this is our apartment
what do you mean
and we have just you know we have a gym
downstairs we have a sauna
we have a pool and we have a jacuzzi and
we have a sky lounge upstairs
viewing the entire of london and this is
exactly what we said we wanted it was
exactly like the plan
everything and in one week i told samuel
and it made it happen so it's not me
samuel
that's mine also we're not in debt
anymore you see that nine grand
oh and on top of that you want to come
and see a piece of land we're brought in
six houses
let's go man my property training
strategies both on youtube and
my courses um thousands of people
started implementing
i set winners on a wednesday up and
winners on a wednesday has been going
now for two years
where every single week i've had people
coming on my youtube channel
to share their story of financial
freedom through my strategies
we've had people like uh ian patterson
who was working in the corporate world
and just thought you know what i'm going
to start looking for lease option
agreements
while i'm commuting back and forth to
work on the train
and then he grew a 2.8 million property
portfolio
left the corporate world got people like
raheem barr
who came here as an orphan from africa
and now he's financially free he's got
his own letting agency
he's actually set up his own training
company and he's helping thousands and
thousands of people
and he's employing people he's helping
his family out
so again i just want to say thank you
because
doing youtube running my youtube channel
inspiring other people getting to
property
it's really really satisfying for me and
thank you for those that have stood with
me not just over the past few months but
over the past six years
you know i've had lots of ups i've had
lots of downs when i posted my first
video on youtube guess what
i wasn't even a millionaire i was just
getting started with
scaling up my deal packaging business
and
i just got married and you've literally
seen you've seen the journal you've seen
me move house
from living in the midlands to now
living in buckinghamshire
[Applause]
[Music]
hello how you doing
this is going to be your new house
oh wow should we do a house tour
yeah do you want to do you want to be
the leader of the house talk because i
don't remember where anything is
i remember i picked this house because
i thought it looked amazing i love that
it's
like this light color on the outside
it's just different see normally i
choose the
investment houses but then at home where
we live
pretty much yeah i'm in charge i get to
choose i get to choose
we i mean last time i viewed the last
house and you never saw it
until we moved in so we moved in but
luckily mandy's got a pretty good day
it's just gorgeous man
massive should we walk around the
outside can you walk around it or
you've seen the upgrades the car
upgrades the holiday upgrades
as my property business has grown i've
been documenting everything
and i'm going to continue to document
everything and i'm going to continue to
teach
and i'm going to continue to help other
people do the same
you've got the house but you didn't have
the energy
and we we phoned the estate agent
and he phoned the estate agent and we
could get it down by five
grand oh my goodness and they
manage the property ten percent
all right i've bought nine houses in the
last two weeks
i'd be very happy to make it around 10
and buy that one
and i'd be happy to give you 500 pounds
uh before we say we'll have a question
he's like your best officer we think we
think
we think it's a property that's going to
make you lots of money for a long time
and you've given us so much today so we
won't
go too hard i mean so we'll say we'll
just say
if you offer us 600 we'll take it and
we'll all go unhappy
because we'll make a lot of money from
that
also it's been so good collabing with
people as well uh collaborating with
other youtubers
having influences on the channel big and
small
the sponsorships the interviews the
guests the podcasts even people like
grant cardone robert kiyosaki
uh the amazing patricia breit james khan
from dragon's dan
it's been an absolute blast i've loved
every minute of it sales really is about
getting what you want i called
gulfstream
two christmases ago and said i need a
jet
we don't have one and then suddenly they
delivered one
yeah how did they find something they
said they did now do you learn the skill
of making fast decisions or is that
something that you feel that you're born
with
you better learn it yeah you better
learn how to make fast decisions i don't
think she paid off her mortgage i think
something or the other i watch samuel
leeds and he talks about this kind of
stuff
so here we are and here and actually i
think that is how i found out about you
or maybe i've seen
your videos before then but yes um i'm
into saving money being good with money
and then into property as well the
satisfying thing for me about doing
youtube
is seeing people succeed off the back of
these videos let me know
in the comments what do you want to see
over the next
1000 videos what videos what content
what do you want to see and i will give
you
what you want to see i'll put it out
there if you're not subscribed please do
you can subscribe up here
if you want to see the list of financial
freedom challenges that i've done you
can check them out here if you want to
see
some of the winners on a wednesday
episodes that we've done you can watch
them right here
please don't forget to subscribe and
don't forget to comment below
what you want to see over the next 1000
videos
thanks peace out god bless